I've actually had the luxury of working
for many many great bosses who have
helped me be Who I am as a leader but I
certainly had one individual in
particular there was a very poor boss he
was very very visionary really was the
CEO of a very large company very
visionary really wanted to take the
company places and he had executives
around him who just wanted to pull the
company down and at the end of the day
you can be visionary but you've got to
follow through and you've got to execute
and this particular and executive did
not execute and he did not follow
through and he really took my words he
he had no backbone to really pull the
company forward when the employees and
shareholders suffered because of it so
the biggest thing is you got to be
visionary you got to follow up with
execution and you got to have a backbone
this is not an easy job being a CEO but
you've got it carry it through you know
it was very interesting because I grew
up actually working for GE very young
and I had responsibility for Asia so a
woman selling to the Japanese in my 20s
so you can imagine all the kinds of
challenges as well as just fantastic
memories I have at that time sorry but I
never thought of myself as different in
the workplace but over the years
especially as I coach other women coming
into the workforce there's absolutely
differences in how you're treated you
know when a it's true when they say
you're good leader a man is tough and a
woman is a name that we won't mention i
am a very tough demanding individual
demanding no different than my
colleagues that are successful that are
men but i've heard the names i've heard
you know how you're supposed to be quiet
in this way or that absolutely labels
come with a very strong successful
female that you don't get in a man's
world so all you have to do do your job
you know affect your shareholders
employees clients positively and and
that's that's all you can do
whether a man or a woman quite frankly
you've got to go for it and you've
really got to learn and put in what it
takes in order to be successful across
any field but especially the business
field but I don't think yet women
believe that they can go all the way to
the top there are very few role models
at the CEO level and even
internationally even less role models so
you just have to you have to get good
mentors you have to really plug into the
networks I myself never plugged into the
woman's networks or anything I'm now
quite involved with that because I do
believe in it and I think it's one way
to help individuals get mentored and be
able to grasp all the way to the top if
that's what they want I have three girls
and a fantastic husband and it is quite
a challenge to balance at all I balance
or I spend as much effort balancing
personal work life that I do being a CEO
that's how challenging it is but I
absolutely have a wonderful support
system couldn't do any of this without
my husband he's just my rock my best
friend my children are growing up
understanding what the world is what the
bit what business is so I include them
in on things that I that I do we went to
France to visit a client so they got to
go on vacation and learn the French
culture and how things work over there
so include them include my family and as
much as I can with work and then also
just the incredible support system from
my husband